[Music]  congratulations go out to pink and her  husband carry heart I'm very lucky the  37 year old singer and 41 year old  former motocross racer have welcomed  their second child the couple already  have a 5 year old daughter willow willow  is all me she's cute like her Papa and  she's mean like her mama in November  pink announced she was expecting by  debuting her baby bump on Instagram with  a message surprise  the Grammy winner had been documenting  her pregnancy journey on social media  showing off her growing bump and sharing  funny posts like this one where she's  posing topless while her daughter hugs  her belly pink caption did the Snuggle  is real  [Music]  you